remember we discussed tight ok now the
categorical quantum computing well I
changed it slightly here well thanks
precursor like thank the organizers for
inviting me to speak at this workshop
I've been really enjoying it I didn't
really know what I wanted to talk about
so I'm going to give a kind of a survey
ish talk and I'm going to try and make
connections to some things that people
said in the previous two days as I go
along so this work kind of spans quite a
long period of time and I've done it
with various people the older stuff with
Bob and we'll see more who's around here
somewhere and the more recent stuff with
Kevin down my PhD student and completely
unfinished half-baked stuff Whitney of
the Bhadra in Oxford okay so
compositionality in categorical quantum
mechanics and I can't want to pick up on
three different aspects of
compositionality in this topic so the
first thing is plain old monoidal
category theory which just trying to do
quantum computing in a string
diagrammatic framework and taking
advantage of that notion of
conventionality second idea of
compositionality is in the equation of
theory of the start taking the idea of
the diagrams as syntax seriously and
finally the idea that this equation of
theory itself can be thought of as a
composite of other theories okay and at
the end I will hopefully sure this is
got something to do with real quantum
computers
okay so let's begin so this idea of
categorical quantum mechanics is
basically saying how much of quantum
mechanics and particularly bit of it we
want for quantum computing how much of
it can be expressed as an internal
theory and an arbitrary monoidal
category or arbitrary given some minimal
amount of structure okay so oh yes I
should emphasize that i'm using the
so-called pessimistic diagram convention
so time goes from the top to the bottom
and all of my pictures right this joke
used to be funny or a thing it's not
that not everything anymore okay so in
all right so what mechanics for me means
finite dimensional pure States so
everything I'm saying here can be
generalized to mixed states by means of
the cpi-m constructor do to Peter
Salinger I'm not going to talk about
that whatsoever so what do we have in
this right in this world we've got some
kind of state spaces which would be
Hilbert spaces we've got this idea that
we're going to combine systems the
tensor product you have some dynamics
which will be typically unitary maps and
important my story this idea of non
degenerate measurements which are
mathematically the same things
orthonormal basis of our spaces so if I
look at all these things that's just
saying I want to work in some symmetric
monoidal category sorry dagger symmetric
I need the dagger so I can talk about
unitarity and for free it will also give
me an inner product but all the rest of
the stuff I actually have to put in
right and so the thing we have to do
here to choose some goods generators and
relations that are to capture as much of
the concrete quantum theory as we can in
this more abstract setting so John
mentioned at his talk idea you could do
this kind of work with decorated course
bands I know how to do some of this and
decorate course plans the rest I don't
know so this is going to be a generators
and relations kind of presentation
okay so let's start with these things
right these are going to be the most
important thing the basis and we're
going to rely on a wonderful theorem of
Jamie Vickery and vodka Candice go
public which says that in the category
of finite dimensional Hilbert spaces or
concrete quantum mechanics as we might
call it then the orthonormal basis are
in by jection with these dagger special
commutative frobenius algebras for now
what I'm just going to say for be Gnaeus
algebra you can pretend all those other
words are there and what is one of those
things it's a four operations the
multiplication some two copies on base
base into the one with an Associated
unit and a cool multiplication for one
copy of the space into two are
associated cool unit and there for
finite dimensional Hilbert spaces they
are all produced in the form with taking
some chosen basis of the space and
mapping each basis vector or the two
copies of that basis vector so that
theorem says there are no others and we
get the multiplication by just taking
the linear joints all these maps okay so
in my pictures is going to look
something like this so multiplication
has two inputs of one output unit has no
one puts in an output and the core
multiplication and core unit are just
the same pictures upside down and in
particular since this is a dagger
algebra the core things are obtained
from the things by taking the dagger
okay so we have also some properties so
the mono I'd part is a mono it so
equations saying that it's associative
it's commutative and that the unit is a
unit for it ok since I have a dagger
category I have all those equations for
free for the comb annoyed part just by
applying the dagger so co commutative
core unit 0 & Co associative and to make
it a phineas algebra I had some
interaction of this mono in the colloid
part namely these equations have to make
it special this equation so
don't worry too much that's a lot to
take in brilla will not be concerned too
much for the details about this so an
associate instructor you can define
whenever you have one of these
rebellious algebra this is a group of
phases so phase for me is it a unitary
map which commutes with the core
multiplied in this kind of a symmetric
way and the same for the multiplication
right and because the algebra is
commutative the phases are always in a
billion group the inverter balcazar are
unitary and the groups of building
because the algebra is commutative okay
so let's do a concrete example talk
about cubits so we have the standard
basis of the cubit which equals 0 and 1
and so this is the Zetas in observable
because these are the eigenstates of Z
so I take 0 cubit the 20 qubit Y cubed
to 1 tensor one the more interesting
thing is the group of phases which are
the group of Zed rotations okay so
pictorially we have the idea that my
algebra is defined by copying those two
antipodal points in the Bloch sphere and
the group of phases is this rotation
group that fixes those two points ok so
I'm saying this in cubits but everything
I'm saying is generically true all right
and so we had quite a lot of equations
and we can reduce almost all of them to
this one theorem which says that if I
have some connected picture in my
diagrammatic language is completely
determined by the number of legs in the
top and bottom and the sum of all the
phases and that some is just the
addition in the face group ok so the
other thing you can take from this
theorem is that this is not very
interesting theory so far right we just
have green spiders right so what we've
got do next is add another observable to
the story
okay so there's no reason we had to take
the Z Spence we can take also the X bin
you can say by the way I've written it
down it is exactly the same except that
instead of 0 1 I have the plus and minus
cats so in terms of the blogsphere
that's what we had before here is a plus
ket here's a minus ket and so the phases
for the X observable are no surprise the
rotations the x axis okay so as well as
being observables Z and expense of the
nice property of being complementary I
also have some additional nice algebra
which means these observables are called
strongly complementary and so we would
like to incorporate some information of
the algebraic level about this
complementarity and that comes from the
following theorem so says two things are
strongly complementary if they jointly
for me hopefully bruh so observable for
us means for being a soulja bruh what
does it mean stated jointly hopf algebra
so if i take the four elements the
Frobenius algebra all the green ones
have another for being in algebra or the
red ones this is there this is X if I
rebrands like so that would be a half
algebra and that would be a different
home faster ah ok do we know what half
algebra is well obviously it consists of
a multiplying a core mode armaan oite
and a coma Lloyd and it obeys these
equations so again you don't have to
remember them but just notice that they
are here there are some nice equations
ok so this ends up producing a very rich
algebraic theory works in a very
generator a very very general setup but
I don't want to talk about the general
case I want to talk specifically about
quantum computing so in particular the
two observers we already saw the X and
the Z so this little setup is called the
ZX calculus and it's a nice formal
language for reasoning about quantum
computing
so the terms of the language are simply
going to be graphs where the vertices
are colored either green for Z or red
for X and the labeled with some alpha
corresponding to element of that
rotation group of the qubit okay and so
any graph with vertices of any arity
connected in this way is a valid term
and language it often be convenient to
have some open edges at the top of the
graph with inputs and some open edges at
the bottom for the outputs okay so we
can give it its standard semantics so it
may not be obvious that the collection
of such diagrams is a monoidal category
and we can define its semantics by
giving a monoidal functor which is just
defined on the vertices by sending them
to a linear map which preserves one of
the two eigen states and adds a phase to
the other okay and then this can be
extended to cover the entire class of
both diagrams so we can represent some
usual things so here's my 0 cubed this
is the picture which produces it
understand semantics here's the plus
qubit there's the picture that produces
it here my Z then X rotations under the
standard semantics the poly matrices
control not I think by this point we
probably realized that any quantum
circuit can be translated into this
notation preserving its usual meaning so
you can see that if I have zero
rotations expectations and see not
that's the universal gate set so any
circuit can be represented in EDX
calculus with the with the same meaning
ok
so for example here is a standard
notation for the circuit which encodes a
qubit into the seven cubits teen code
there's a presentation of the same thing
in ZX so I didn't tell you what these
are but these are just syntactic sugar
for something I could define ok the
equations which I've kind of i'm showing
here just you can see them but
essentially what we're doing is taking
all the more complicated things and
compressing little bit done so here's
the equations for being frobenius
algebra here's the equations for being
helpful jibri here's something which is
specific to being in cubits which i'll
not talk about and so we can use this to
prove interesting things so here is a
famous exercise three see notes in a row
should be the swap can we prove this
there is the proof in the ZX calculus
relying on relatively simple
diagrammatic manipulations ok you can
also represent more complicated things
and circuits so here's a square graph
state so sorry square lattice graph
state and in general you should think of
the interpretation of a ZX calculus term
as being a tensor network so the lots of
things you can write down which are not
circuits or not correspond to any
particular model of quantum computation
but they're always representing linear
maps which can be built as tensor
networks this picture you have wires
coming off to the top two left the right
after the bottom so it was me the intent
when i made the patriot was this just
carry on and in Italy but if you want
you could just pretend they're not there
so the the one spring at the bottom are
intended to be the fact that this is an
actual qubit which you may interact with
and the ones going out to the sides are
ok all in the same thing potential
interactions or something else but I
didn't really intend to be taken
seriously
okay but if you did want to take this
exactly as written to mean something and
you say this is a state it's state
spaces count the number of open wires
that number of qubits that particular
state interesting like the ground state
of Sun this is the reason i'm writing
this piece because it's a universal
resource state for measuring based
quantum computing so I think it is
supposed to be easy to produce the
ground state something but I have to let
so it was more about physics that's all
that question right so by the spider
theorem any composition of things of the
same color can be marriage to adult with
more wires okay I was deep retained
pradesh good then i will i will dare to
do this so since Jamie was showing off
his to all the other day I thought I
wanted to show off what I say mine Alex
Kissinger has done almost all work on
this so here is a picture in zetex
calculus of a circuit this part of it is
the encoder sending a single qubit into
the seven cubits teen code the middle
part is the error syndrome measurement
under the circumstance that no error has
happened and the last part of it is the
decoder back into a single qubit you say
a word about the steam code
it's an error correcting code 11 cubic
goes to seven cubits it's relatively
simple and yeah it's one of the older
ones right so I'm going to attempt it's
by my most part in for a start right so
all the rules of direct calculus have
been programmed into this system and
should now be able to just set it going
and so what would I say it was i was
going to encode a qubit test for errors
find no errors and then decode it so
there should be the identity right so it
can go off doing graffiti writing step
by step by step going to those axioms
and we just get a single wire right okay
so maybe it's me but all right just one
water okay hey so this is quite
practical right you can verify
interesting things from cotton for
shooting this way
so I've only shown you a little bit of
the idea of how we can do quantum theory
in this this language for much more
in-depth reference there's this book
written by Alex Kissinger and Bob cook
so Alex was the guy who did most of the
work on my quantumatic so this book
itself can be seen as a quantum process
which turned Alex from this into this
but I didn't have such an influence on
Bob to be honest so I don't know what
you call it with a composite completely
positive when acting on the left with
the identity there's nothing okay
because the boat was a catalyst for this
process okay so I want to move with my
second my second thing which is by far
the sketchiest thing I'm going to say so
let's try to take this idea of the
syntax seriously so oh yes before I move
on in the exotics calculus because these
red dots and green dots that each one of
them is a dagger special for various
algebra which means in the terminology
of Brandon this is a hypergraph category
but it's a hypergraph category in two
different ways depending whether you
take the edge structure to be the green
things or the red things so I don't
really quite know how to make sense of
that because this is the two different
graph structures carry different
information okay so but we can still
compose things in this push out style
that John talked about so here I've got
a simple term you know I've got another
simple term I've been identified these
open edges of the inputs outputs inputs
outputs and in order to say I'm going to
compose them I'm simply going to
identify these two dots with those
outputs and those inputs i compute the
pusher in a suitable category of graphs
all right so I'm not going to say too
much more about this but if you can
understand this picture then you've
probably got the idea right already so
this thing is found common and both and
in the combined thing there's only one
copy of it
so we can also kind of think of the
tensor product this way except with an
empty intersection between the two
graphs so they're both getting mapped
into the disjoint Union but the overlap
is trivial and in similar ways you can
imagine partially composing things so on
and since this ambient category is
compact we don't really need to care
which ones are the inputs on the outputs
it can still make sense mathematically
again think of it as he as a tensor
network rather than as a process so this
idea of doing things that push out is
also useful for equation or reasoning so
if you cast your mind back a few slides
to this proof that i showed you this is
one of the steps in the proof right and
this is not an axiom in my my system
this is a theorem right so i should be
able to prove it somehow and of course
the way that we do is that we identify
this part which has changed and so how
did i get from this graph to this graph
I appealed to this axiom so this looks a
bit complicated because this is actually
an axiom schema but if I make it more
concrete by instantiating all the
variables it's just this right and so
you can oops you can kind of see that
this graph is occurring here and this
graph is occurring here and that's
what's happened so let's try and be a
little bit more precise the idea that I
might even lips my way I might even
write this equation it's kind of hinging
on the fact that these things are the
same type in some reasonable sense and
the way that we express that is the fact
that I've got this thing which is the
boundary of this graph on this graph I
know they are the same right so this is
just some open vertices and I injective
Lee map them into this one and I cover
the boundary and I injective Lee map
them into this one and I cover the
boundary so if they are having the same
interface they could reasonably be said
to be equal to the different types that
wouldn't mix
alright so I wanted to to use this
equation in this proof right so the next
thing I have to do is say okay let's
find whoops Norway let's find this graph
in the thing that I'm actually
interested in so again this is an
injective graph for morphism so identify
this sub graph here on the next step is
to say okay well I'm going to want to
have something which is going to mediate
between this graph and the one which I
want to get at the end and so the
approach you're taking is called double
pushchair you're rewriting and what it
says is I want to find a corner here so
I can embed this one and then here and
so under some not too strong assumptions
you can always find this graph called
push out compliments such that this
square is a push out right and what you
have this square then you can compute
this push out right and that it gives
you the graph that you wanted okay so i
think is probably obvious already that
because i have a tensor and
compositional structure in my grant
category this your equation or
redirecting also has a structure of
monoidal category right for the
morphisms will be rewrite steps in fact
is kind of richer because you can do all
kinds of embeddings of complicated
things into the integrals and so this is
a very kind of sketchy but I want to
make a small link back to David stock
this is got double for sherry writing so
I'll link back to David's talk and just
think with this bit in the middle so
effectively what I'm saying here is I'm
going to have somewhere and home of the
shape in my graph so let's call it an X
and so the thing which was my picture
compliment was the graph with a hole
called X which is the place where things
of type X may be substituted into it
alright suppose you don't have to think
very hard to see this is exactly an
opera in David sense especially since I
might take the tensor product with
things and so on
so one interesting question might be to
ask let's say from this picture when is
it reasonable to ask for a solution to
an equation x equals this graph so for
people who are interested in quantum
programming languages this seems to be
pertinent okay so that's a bit sketchy
let's move on how much time do I have
now great okay so composite theories so
let's change tack so we talked a bit but
how once we have our theory we can do
equation reasoning and a composite away
in various directions so where do these
equations come from anyway so I'm going
to introduce ally of a prop so I'm sure
most of you have heard of this before
cuz I'm so sure somebody said it
yesterday when a prop is just monoidal
category where there's no types on the
wire so rights imagine string diagram
every wire is as good as every other
wire you can plug them together okay and
a dagger prop is a prop where you can
reverse things using a stager factor
okay and the idea of these things is
trying to formalize an idea of universal
algebra so algebra would just be a
functor from the from the problem into
some other system so i'll make that more
precise in a minute but first let's have
a quick tour with the syntactic
presentation of a prop so again we'll
have some set of generators and some set
of equations will generate all the
possible and string diagrams I of the
generators are quotient by the equations
so we can form the core product I you
the disjoint union of two probes just by
taking the disjoint union of all
generators and destroy you you know of
all the equations so that's very very
straightforward okay I'll come back to
that in a minute so here's an example if
I take my generators as being these two
symbols notice the type 2 to 10 to 1 and
these equations you probably recognize
these are the equations for being a
cumulative monoid so whenever I have a
functor from the prop em of commutative
monoids in the song
other place I've described our ma noi in
the other place but if I won't talk
about cole monoids it's exactly the same
except everything is backwards ok and so
we're going to do now is think about how
we can make more interesting theories
out of simpler theories and this work is
Steve lakh from 2004 and so the way that
we go but it is by using a little bit
heavier category theory than I don't
then I want to talk about you see that
props as I just described or mon ads in
a certain category monads admit
distributive laws okay so but if a pair
of mono aids distributes then I can
think of it as I sorry Mon add that I
can think of it as a monad in itself so
what does this mean that I've got two
props or what I want to have then is
some collection of equations for every
composable pair of one prop the other I
can commute and past each other that's
okay so if i have a distributive law one
of the good things that it gives me is a
normal form result so if I could always
commute the red stuff past the green
stuff and everything in the composite
prop will be some green star followed by
some red stuff right and so what is the
if I have to two props what is the
composite in this case it's just the two
equation of theories we started with and
some extra equations we get from this
distributive law or said another way I
take the cool product prop and I
quotient by the equations okay so for
example we can think of the special
community frobenius algebras so here we
have the prop of colloids and the cop
prop of mono I want to commute the
colloids past the mono it so here is the
equations so we can read them towards
the middle right so here is a term from
the coma noids here is a term from the
mono and the equation says can you them
past each other same here same here
okay so in this sense special immunity
for BDS algebras are a composite prop in
this sense okay so let me define
something else let's take a prop which
has this generators the elements of song
group and the equation i'm going to ask
is the composition in the prop is just
the multiplication in the group if i
combine my frobenius algebras prop with
this prop of grip elements according to
these rules you can see again i've got a
rule so i can go past the small right
structure or i can come back before this
kimono structure it's not exactly
composition the way that I suggested but
it's a triple composite okay so normal
form that we get is some mono things
some group things some cool monoid
things so this is another statement of
the spider theorem that I showed you at
the beginning okay and in particular if
I take the group G to be the circle
group and I'm talking about the phases
in the xenex calculus again the by
algebra is are the same except this time
it's ma noi going past como noids so you
see here here Mahanoy Cole annoyed and
on the other side of the equation the
other way around and for a little bit
more work you can do the same trick for
hop algebra so the bad news is that we
can't get all the way to the phils NX
calculus as a composite prop in this
sense so we can form the prompt of the
green spiders on the prop of the red
spiders we can have this factorization
we also an alternating sequence of red
and green things but we don't get this
distributive law and the reason
basically say is because of the phases
so if this was true then every X
rotation would commute with every said
rotation right which is obviously false
so for the full theory we don't have a
chance but for every interesting sub 3
we have a distributive law and as we
have interesting normal forms and this
will be enough for some interesting
applications
how much two minutes okay so this is
happy let's go so here picture of a
circuit I just made it up randomly okay
who cares what it does well I can
translate it into inputs I pits right
remember so I can translate this into
that ice calculus and that's a standard
translation ok so again you can still
see I'm basically preserving this idea
that certain wires are the persistent
history of a physical system going
through this picture this is completely
post hoc lots of things i can write down
and don't have this property but
everything which came from a circuit
will do okay so let's let's mess with it
now so i'm going to take whatever i see
a phase i'm going to pull it out alright
so i just unspotted things and stretch
them out to the outside okay so it's the
same right I've just read things around
okay so now it's not really obvious what
kind of perspective I can take on this
physically okay but algebraically I can
say something interesting because this
box in the middle you will see consist
entirely of green co multiplies and red
multiplies therefore is an expression in
language of hopf algebras and therefore
it has a normal form which in this
instance is this one okay so you see
green stuff red stuff connections the
connections are completed just by
counting the paths and the thing you
started with modulo 2 it's not very
difficult to do okay so you might think
Oh what does this mean physically well I
can take the perspective of measurement
based corner computing and see instead
of thinking of paths through my diagram
as being cubits I think of the vertices
has been cubits so every single vertex
year and I think of its physical cubit
the ones which are not connected to the
input so i think it was being prepared
the ones which are connect which are not
connected to the outputs we think of as
being measured so now i have the
description of some cancer network which
can be realized by an NVQ see i'm going
to measure all the stuff with no angle
the next measurement whole stuff angles
will be a measurement in the XY plane
okay so i can make physical sense of
this and in fact i can make sense of any
directs calculus term in this way but
this is a particularly interesting thing
because i look at the structure of this
you can see I have small numbers of
qubits interacting in this big massive
couplings in the middle so i might say
oh well maybe these are few qubit ion
traps i'm going to do some some
measurements and this stuff in the
middle is a large optical interconnector
and then you will see this is exactly
the architecture being proposed for the
UK quantum computer bid by the now
network quantum information technology
people so I'm kind of proposing that
this kind of normalization procedure is
a reasonable way to generate programs
can run on this computer of course this
is I kind of not worked out right so in
general we don't know if this can be
done deterministically for specific
examples you can apply the usual flow
techniques but again this form is very
particular so you might be able to do
something better we haven't worked today
yet and second of all what is the the
trade-off nice everywhere I have an on
Clifford gate I pay for it with an extra
two physical qubits ok so that's that's
one trade-off the second trade-off is
the depth of the circuit is paid for
essentially in the complexity of this
interconnect and so I weekend don't know
what the trade-offs are at the moment
okay but I hope I hope it was fun to see
that you can do something useful alright
thanks everyone
[Applause]
we're waiting for questions um so I'm my
student Daniel psychologist for a deeper
on on double sharp crack free writing
we require to do
you might take your ways of writing
graphs using an automatic and prove that
those are two morphism night's fight
this paper she's all fit together in
some nice I'm kind of surprised no one's
done that yet and it's it's definitely
rewriting of these monoidal terms must
be a by category took some work
the CX calculus using like c star is
your group sticking that in there and
just using that to keep track of the
phases when they don't commute oh you
mean by see stuff um so you did this
example where you also have a group and
they're right okay so me and you being
finite dimensions generally speaking but
you can do this construction for any
billion groups and any dimension of
underlying space there are some kind of
mutual constraints for you don't you
might not get a model if you choose
badly your group and your underlying
space but there's a general so the work
I think that Kevin done is a general
construction of theories like this for
any choice of observable and any group
of dynamics that preserves that
submersible observable
when you had right at the end you were
pulling out the phases from the main
body that does that then turn into
teleported rotation gates essentially my
donnell maybe and the if that's the case
then what you then when you try to map
it to anchor had one mode from one
so it is basically the standard and b QC
picture right so I could write a rim
this differently where everything would
be be greed and what this this link here
basically means that there's a cubit
year there's a cubit year and I've
effectively applied a cz between them so
that's the meaning of this link here and
all the other links in this picture in
fact i'm also curious about how you're
turning this around to talk about a week
you see in this language so zetex should
be smelling complete for some fragments
of quantum mechanics when interpolated
finally and now you're just proposing a
completely different interpret the wires
right so this is a linear operator that
you will get from the positive branch of
the oven mb QC which you can you can
write down based in this picture so if
you don't get the plus 10 come in every
measurement that you'll get something
different and this was talking about we
haven't quite figured out when this is
going to be deterministic but this is
the tensor network corresponding to that
branch of the MV QC so the fact that
these are the input cubits and these are
the output qubits right and everything
else will be measured away but in this
picture does that make sense
just just not add into that and you can
always play the trick that you post late
if you've got measurements because
essentially you're just in the
corrections
okay so sorry English I ask this because
I problem so I'm going to say yes just
by appealing so Miriam backings has
pretty result that the ZX calculus is
signed a complete for the stabilizer
fragment of quantum mechanics so we know
it's not complete for everything but
it's not complete for all of quantum
mechanics but the implication of this is
that if you took away any axiom then you
wouldn't be able to prove every true
statement and by the stabilizer fragment
although simo is going to talk more
about this right ok trailer single